♪
>>ret: BREAKING NIGHT
ACTUALLY JUST MINUTES AGO
THORITIES INVTIGATING THE
OOTI DEATH OF A FILM CREW
MEMBER ON AOVIE S HAVE NOW
OBTAINED A SRCH WARRANT F
THE PHONE, T CELL PHONEBELONGIN.
E ACT WASOLDING THE GUN
THAT FIRED THE FAL ST, WHICH
ALSO INJED THE MOVIE'S
DIRECTOR.
AGAIN, BREAKG WITHIN THE PAST
FEW MINES, CORRESPONNT MATT
FINN I IN LOS ANGELES.
GOOD EVENI, MATT.>> GOODVENING,E
ERIFF WAS GRAED AARRANT TO
SEIZ AND SEARCH ALEC BALDWIN'S
CELL PHONE.
COURT DOCUMEN REVEAL
INVESTIGATOR WILL DOWNLOAD A
PHONE BELIED TO B A IONE.S
THE SAN FE ERIFF'SFFICE IS
SEEKING MORENFORMATION IN THE
OOTING DTH OF HUTINS.
E DIRECTOR OF PHOTOGRHER ON
THE FILM SET RUST STARRG ALEC
BALDWIN.
SHEAS SHOTND KILLED I
OCTOBERHEN  FED AUN
BEEVED TO BE A CD PRO G.
IN A TELEVION INTERVIEW
BALDWI HAS SINCE DENIED PULLING
THE TRIGG NO.
ONE S BEEN CRGED.
THE DISTRIC ATTORNEY HAS N
RULED OUT CMINAL CHARGES IN
THIS CAS THE FILM'S DIRECTOR